[موسيقى]
مشهد للقوه للسلطه في تمام تجلياتها لا
يحتمل خدشا بمعارضه كتومه او فصيحه لا
يحتمل منازعه عليها او تشكيكا فيها لكن
رجلا تجرا في لحظه سكره بقوته ونفوذه
وبغير قليل من الاشتراء على الكريمليل ان
يحدث نفسه بقتش هذه الصوره صوره بوتين
وصوره الجيش الروسي الذي يخوض حربا ضد
اوكرانيا لم يكن ذلك الرجل احدا غير يفجين
انه السجين السابق الذي امضى في السجن تسع
سنوات من اصل عقوبه بلغت اثنتي عشره سنه
بسبب فساده واحتياله وسرقاته
نهايه الطموح في اعمال المطاعم وصناعه
الطعام ويتحول الى متعهد بعدد من
المناسبات الرسميه في الكرملين حتى لحق به
لقب طباخ الرئيس يرد السليط اللسان يمكن
ان اسمى بدقه اكثر جزار الرئيس ولا يدري
ان الليالي حبالا
سيعجن الطباخ بيجوجين كل عناصر تجربته
كمجرم ورجل اعمال وصاحب شبكه علاقات مع
كبار المسؤولين ليصنع شركه امنيه سيكون
لها صيت اي يصيت في روسيا وخارجها انها
فاجنر ملكه البنادق المستاجره للقتل
بنادق تحرس السلطات الاله للسقوط من ان
تسقط في سوريا وفي عدد من الدول الافريقيه
من بينها افريقيا الوسطى ومالي في ليبيا
ستجد فاجنر في صف اللواء المتقاعد حليفه
حفتر تتكسب من القتال معه ومن حراسه ابار
النفط تحت سيطرته في السودان اسم فاغنر
ارتبط بقوات الدعم السريع وبالتنقيب عن
الذهب وحراسته
كانت حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا او ما يسميها
بوتين بالعمليه العسكريه الخاصه هي
المناسبه التي ستجعل اسم فاغنر مرادف
للتعبير عن الوطنيه والتضحيات الكبيره من
اجل الوطن وذلك بما احدث جنود فاغنن من
تحول كبير في سير العمليات العسكريه خاصه
في مدينه باغموت لكن لحظه الصعود الى
القمه كانت هي عينها لحظه الاندفاعة الى
السفح
انقلب بريروجين على الجيش الروسي واوسع
قادته سبا وشتما ولعنا وقال انهم خذلوه في
ارض المعركه ولم يكتفوا بعدم مده بالاسلحه
والذخائر بل قتلوا جنوده كذلك
ويمضي ابعد من ذلك فيصف الحرب على
اوكرانيا بالعار
ثم يصل الى النقطه الخطره التي لا عود
بعدها وهي اعلانه التمرد على الجيش الروسي
في الثالث والعشرين من يونيو حزيران
الماضي فامر جنوده بالزحف على العاصمه
الروسيه موسكو للانتقام من قياده القوات
الروسيه وقال انهم ضللوا الرئيس وانهم
وراء الاداء المتواضع للجيش الروسي في
الحرب
لكن الزحف على موسكو يتوقف فجاه باتفاق
سعى فيه الرئيس بيلاروسي الكزاندر
لوكاشينكو بين الكرملين وبين فاجنر تم
بموجبه انهاء التمرد واسقاط العقوبه عن
يفقيني وجنوده كثيرون قالوا
قد حرر شهاده وفاته بيده يوم تمرد على
الرئيس بوتين بعد شهرين من ذلك التمرد
ستهوي طائره
عموديا الى الارض منهيه حياته وحياه رفيقه
لمثل اوتكين الشخصيه الثانيه من حيث
الاهميه داخل فاغنر لما هوت الطائره وهل
فجرت ام اسقطت هل كانت تدبيرا ام كان
حادثا لا يد لاحد فيه اسئله الايامات
اللثام عن سرها قريبا ربما وما مصير فاجنر
بعد مصر زعيمها في تحليل بنيه مليشيا ان
تماسكها مرتبط الى حد كبير بزعيمها فان
اختفى تفرغ جمعها خاصه اذا كان ذلك القائد
كيف جئني
وخاصه اذا كانت الميليشيا بلا مشروع
ايدولوجي وكان دافعها الى القتال هو الكسب
المادي
ولا احد غيره هو من سيقول للعالم انه
يفجئين بريكوجين قتلقي حتفه يعزي اسرته
ويذكره ببعض خير ثم يصدر الستار
انتهى التمرد